dr hh blink thrice if you need help
i'm doing just fine
we're doing just fine we're
we're putting on a show here
i've talked to friends about lab leak
and vaccines all this so this is that
was the first part of this question the
rest of it is an actual question i think
um i've talked to friends about lab leak
and vaccines all were convinced that i
was worshiping alec jones i haven't lost
friends yet but it feels lonely do you
see any signs of hope
yeah this bit about um
alex jones wasn't as wrong as they told
us he was is um
concerning to a lot of people
yeah
um that's always a question
and it is also true that you know
the magic trick is visible from certain
places
the idea that to oppose vaccine mandates
to oppose
any vaccine to have any doubt about the
efficacy safety the wisdom of any
vaccine renders you an anti-vaxxer no
matter how vaccinated you may be
is
a tell
right that is the monster letting you in
on a secret which is that the term
anti-faxer doesn't mean a goddamn thing
it's a threat right it's a stigma that
will be uh appended to you irrespective
of your beliefs and behavior and that
you should be very very frightened and
you should run from that stigma you
should do what they tell you so they
don't wield it at you and the answer is
don't listen to them right if they're
going to define anti-vaxxers so
everybody's an anti-vaxxer well then
fine right then it's a meaningless term
they did the same with racist right it's
the same trick same thing it's the same
and you know we we are the living proof
of this right we were the racists of
evergreen in spite of the fact that we
are the opposite of racists so if you
saw that and you stuck with the story
long enough to figure out that hey
people are screaming about you being
racist but there doesn't seem anything
racist about you and in fact there are
an awful lot of students of a wide
diversity of descriptions who seem to
think that that's a preposterous claim
right if you saw that then you realize
oh
racist isn't a description of something
it's a threat right it's a weapon it's a
weapon
and so anyway i mean
i can't remember when we only though say
it again
that doesn't mean it doesn't feel lonely
the person asking the question said
um yeah just increasingly it's lonely
well
it is
and it isn't
if you i mean it depending upon the
circumstances of your life it may be
that you don't have
anyone to find but
our experience has been
that there are some people
who have broken the wrong way in each of
these circumstances
and they've been perfectly horrible
and then there have been other people
who've shown up and who have shined and
i would say in no case
has the
replacement of people who have been
awful with people who have been good
been a downgrade in
the number of friends the quality of
friends the decency of those friends in
every case it's been an upgrade and so
the question really is are you
remaining attached to people who had
such weakness of character
that they fell for these tricks
and are you overlooking the possibility
that
there might be new people who
would be much higher quality and much
more rewarding to hang out with and i
you know the the weird caveat of that
well what heather and i have seen is
that our friend group is really eclectic
it cuts across all kinds of lines right
that has been very much to the good it
is a much more interesting dynamic
friend group and yeah it contains people
who have
you know radically other ways of viewing
the world but that's all to the good as
far as we're concerned so
who are you overlooking is the question
who that does have ears to hear
uh are you
failing to see
and what would happen if you uh
if you try to team up with them
well i don't disagree with any of that
but i don't think it
i doubt that it is perfectly responsive
to the person asking the question
because
um
it will be obvious
to most people watching us
that
many of the costs that we endure for
being public with our
um with what we do
uh
but
one of the benefits is hidden in the
ants that you just gave which is that
people find us
and um if you're if you're not public if
you know if your job whether or not you
intended it to be or not
uh isn't to public declare publicly
declare where it is that you stand on
issues then how is it that people would
find you you know how is it the person
asking the question well we'll find
these people who i know exist who but
whom you are alluding to um but in this
in this way we are this is the this is
one of the
the ways that it's easier
yeah
yeah although
now that i get the question better i do
think that there is uh an answer
in that
right
you and i also find that with people and
you know most people don't know who we
are um so we have a lot of those
conversations too and if you are bold
about
confessing your doubts and your concerns
and you just
you know you
you take the risk of letting people know
that you're not on board with the
conventional narrative and that actually
you've come to understand some different
things i believe you will be absolutely
shocked by the percentage of
your fellow citizens who are also
possessing of doubts afraid to talk and
feeling a bit lonely and you know
go with it
talk to people let them know you know
what i don't think this advice makes any
sense and here's why and uh see what you
get back i'll be i'd be shocked if you
didn't find a lot of kindred spirits
[Music]